we are on sets of the Tamron Hall show
so do you still get that excite when you
hear like this is the Tamron Hall show
like hearing that oh my god we're in our
two-month mark and I get when I walk out
to the audience because I haven't seen
them before walking out I hear I'm below
the set but walking out I still get that
adrenaline rush in fact um my cousin
makes fun of me because she said yours
you always out of breath as soon as you
start makes me feel like I ran a
marathon walk three steps to the camera
it's very fun I mean you've been doing
TV for a long time but yeah what does it
like to have a show that is your name
like this is you it's surreal no it's
it's my name but it's this huge team of
people which makes it a big
responsibility but one that you know the
satisfaction of when you pull off a show
with a team it just makes it a more you
know it's more emotional yeah I can be
honest with you it's it's a much more
emotional experience than any other part
of my journey of 25 years I've loved
every job pretty much that I've had
except for maybe when I sold jewelry
having the name is a big responsibility
but it's an emotional connection to the
product and the team that is heightened
so we go live at 10:00 a.m. 10:00 a.m.
so what's your routine that give a
little people insider like what you do
in the morning like what's the timeline
of things my alarm clock goes off at the
very last minute which would be around
5:45 I instantly turn on the baby cam in
my child's room to see what he's doing
he's usually starting it a little wiggle
worm to wake up kids my husband I pray I
run upstairs to get my son and I spend
30 minutes with him just kind of vibing
he's already awake talking to him about
his experience month all and then I head
out the door with my team straight to
hair and makeup and we start plotting
and planning any last-minute finishes
the good thing about this show is with
this team of very experienced producers
we work out a lot of the kinks before we
get in that day okay so that the morning
of is really just getting a little shine
because it's like a
football player you know he's not
practicing the play that day that game
day you've practiced that whole week
yeah so that the game day you can focus
on the game so we try to do all of the
practice before the day of the show so
that can just give a few high-fives yeah
and get ready to go do you have like a
last minute thing that you do like any
rituals that you do superstition
meditate
Transcendental Meditation and I have
fallen off a little bit because it's
been busy in the morning but I tried as
best I can get in on my morning
meditation it just makes me feel clearer
I yeah
clear I'm but on the mission you know
and I and I definitely one of the
meditation things that I do in
meditation I really ask for my words to
mean something and my words to have
direction and that my words always make
people feel included probably the
opposite of meditation would be boxing
and I go pick up my son I go to after I
leave here I'm headed to the ring I box
for about an hour and my son hangs out
with me and then we go have our little
after boxing meal ya know raw eggs like
rockin right let's say you're both
having to get used to this like talk
show routine but also be a mom these
first few months - so is that fearing
both those schedules out how do you make
them work you don't know you can each
day you know you call audibles when
necessary you know if it's too cold out
today I won't take him to the boxing
class with me he'll stay home and then
we'll hang out there it's just you know
you call it day to day the show is live
my life is live right you can't edit
things into perfection and that's really
what I've tried to do as a new mom as a
new talk show host life is not tidy
right it doesn't always work out love
isn't tidy you know my husband and I
just had argument yesterday or some
mindless announcer but we live to fight
another day no pun intended to boxing
but you know it's nothing it's the quest
to find this tidy space that I think
where's all of us down yeah and for me
I've just embraced that it's not tidy
and my son's diaper leaked the other day
and
like okay I got it and the poor child is
now drinking because I did so if the
drinks diaper becomes a metaphor for all
things I'll embrace right yeah your time
that's they show you always talk about
like kind of the headlines of the day is
it weird now that that world is very
much in the headlines of the day like
with Rowan and Pharaohs book coming out
a few weeks goes it's not weird it's
emotional because there are very serious
allegations and so when people ask me
about it in interviews I always take a
pause because these are real hurtful
things and I don't take lightly any
person saying that they were assaulted
or or felt marginalized or dehumanized
so for me I don't treat it like a
soundbite for a question that I've been
asked yeah I handle it the same way I
handle the death of my sister and these
are real painful things and they are not
for me an opportunity to have a clip
right on a show or an answer yeah it's
it's real yeah like are you like who's
obviously like Ann Curry is coming out
talking about it or sorry Ann Curry came
out saying she was aware of something
and sent something NBC like we knew that
Murphy era said something like are you
surprised that this stuff is coming out
where people were aware I guess you know
I think anyone would be surprised yeah
and when you read the allegations I
think that to say that I'm not surprised
I don't even know how to honestly
process that because listen we all know
that in every industry every single
industry there are people who have
that's why HR departments were created
they weren't created just for the media
in any workplace
anytime someone feels that someone's
boot is on their head and they can't get
up for a
to have the life that we all deserve
that doesn't exist in one industry and
then when you talk about sexual
harassment and all that doesn't exist in
one industry when you get into specific
allegations of course they become
shocking there's no way in the world
that I could tell you otherwise but I
don't treat it like a storyline in a
movie or a TV show I've been too close
to crime I've been too close to the
survivors of domestic violence I spend a
lot of time with women who feel like
they have no hope so whether it's
someone in a building where I work or
someone at a shelter that I've helped I
don't take any of this lightly and I
don't treat it like it's a plot yeah
because it's people yeah I think like
going back yet this show like you're
really giving a voice to those stories
their own necessary see on other shows
so yeah what do you hope the impact of
your show will be for people I hope it
reminds us that talk never goes out of
style yeah talk is not the new black
it's not the new it's not trendy talk is
something that we're all able to do all
we need is a table a chair to feel safe
and let's get in there and chat it up